YURI GRINSHTEYN: During
an incident or an outage,
your first priority is
triage and mitigation, not
root cause analysis.
But there may be times you
still need to debug especially
in production if that's
the only environment where
you can reproduce the issue.
But you can't afford to
redeploy to add more logging
or debugging code.
So what do you do?
Today, we'll look at debugging
in production, the Stackdriver
Debugger.
This is the Stack doctor.
In the past, situations like
these required developers
to add additional
instrumentation to their code
and wait for a new deployment
to get more insight.
But what if you could just
inspect the code in production
or add logging on the fly
without having to redeploy?
This is what Stackdriver
Debugger is built for.
Let's look at an
example node.js app
to see how to add
debugger to your service.
We'll put the link to the
repo in the video description.
We add the debugger agent
at the very top of our code
and give the agent
the parameters
needed to authenticate
to the API
and specify the service
we'll be debugging.
Once our app is
running, we can go
to the debugger screen
in the cloud console
and see that our
service has checked in
and is ready for debugging.
The next step is
to tell Debugger
where our source code is.
Our sample app's
code is on GitHub,
so we can select that option.
But we can have
Debugger use source code
from Google Cloud Source
Repositories, GitLab,
or Bitbucket, or even from
our local workstation.
Once we select the location
of the source code,
it's shown on the screen.
Our setup is done, and we
can start using Debugger.
Debugger lets us debug in
production in two ways.
First, it allows us
to create snapshots
that let us inspect the
state of our variables
that specify points in the code.
The second, lets us have
more logging on the fly.
Let's take a look at both.
To create a new snapshot,
click on a line of code
where you would like to capture
the state of our variables.
The next time the line
of code is executed,
a snapshot is created.
A snapshot shows us the
values of the local variables
at the specified
execution point.
We can also add
expressions to capture
static or global
variables that are not
part of the local variable
set or perform calculations
like a duration.
We've now seen how to
use snapshots to inspect
variable values in our code.
This is really
helpful when we're
debugging to figure out if
there's a mistake in our code.
But what if we want to
add more debug logging?
Stackdriver Debugger also allows
us to add logging on the fly.
That is to essentially
create additional log
entries that get ingested
into Stackdriver Logging.
Adding one is as easy as
switching to the logpoint tab,
selecting a line of
code, and then specifying
the message to be written.
You can use this to log
the value of a variable
and then use the Log Viewer
to see the value for each time
the line of code is hit.
Once we add the logpoint,
additional log entries
are created.
The logpoint will
persist for 24 hours.
This is a great way to get
better debugging information
to more clearly understand what
our code is actually doing.
Debugging in production
sounds scary,
but Stackdriver
Debugger makes it easy
and lets you do it without
having to change your code
or redeploy your app.
Thank you for joining me today,
and come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.